[Musik]
willkommen liebe hörerinnen liebe hörer
zu einer neuen sonder folge unseres
bücher podcasts aus dem literatur aus
frankfurt am 2 februar war dort peter
stamm zu gast mit seinem neuen roman das
archiv der gefühle es moderierte melanie
mühl
ein herzliches willkommen auch von
meiner von unserer seite schön dass sie
da sind noch ein paar sätze zu peter
stammen sie natürlich alle kennen ein
paar titel sein durchbruch 98 mit
wagners der erste roman von dem er
selbst sagt dass der text nicht mehr
peinlich gewesen sei es folgte blitzeis
von reich-ranicki sehr gelobt viele
weitere bücher an einem tag wie diesen
2007 sieben jahre 2009 und das archiv
der gefühle in diesem jahr sehr viele
preise sie werden auch in amerikanischen
übersetzt ich freue mich sehr sie
moderieren zu dürfen und was bei ihnen
ja immer wieder auffällt dass die
protagonisten in ihrem roman das sind
oft immer wieder männer die so ein
bisschen unschlüssig im leben stehen und
nicht so genau wissen wohin woher rührt
ihre faszination für diesen typus mensch
der so auf der suche ist also 2 1 bin
ich gleich selbst ein bisschen so auch
vor allem auch beim schreiben also es
ist mein schreiben ist ja nicht so dass
ich hingehen plan mache und dann das
buch schreibe sondern ich
schreibe im grunde genauso ich schau mal
was kommt und
es stößt einem einfach mehr zu wenn man
keinen plan hat ich sage immer dass es
so wie beim reisen wenn man wenn man so
eine gruppenreise macht und da weiß man
schon voraus am dritten tag wird dann
morgen wird die altstadt besichtigt am
nachmittag der dom
und das vielleicht einen halben tag zur
freien verfügung oder fürs shopping ich
reise lieber so dass ich aber mal ja nur
hingehen und schau was darin geschieht
und und genauso sind das eben auch die
figuren die mich interessieren weil den
können eben dinge zustoßen weil sie
keinen plan haben diese figuren sie
haben ja auch eine zeitlang psychologie
studiert und auch in der psychiatrie mal
kurz gearbeitet hat dieses studium ihren
ihren blick geschärft auf menschen kommt
ihnen das jetzt bei der
figurenentwicklung zugute ich bin mir
nicht sicher ich sage immer nein weil
weil ich das nicht so toll fand das
studium aber vermutlich halt dann doch
also das sagen wir aber es waren eher
die in anführungszeichen fälle die mich
interessiert haben ich habe auch die
lösung nie interessiert also es war
immer spannend zu sehen was alles
geschieht in also wie wie menschen sein
können aber wenn man sie behandelt muss
man natürlich immer die komplexität
reduzieren da muss man immer aus einem
menschen ein einfall machen ich sage gar
nicht dass das falsch ist aber es ist
halt dann
immer ein bisschen enttäuschend dass man
diese komplexität dann einfach reduziert
auf eine art auf eine psychische
erkrankung und sagt das ist halt
borderline oder das ist depression wo
man eigentlich denkt das ist vielmehr
das ist jeder mensch ist was wie eine
welt halt bevor sie gleich aus ihrem
text lesen und wir dann den typischen
stamm sound hören ist habe ich eine
frage das habe ich nicht gelesen und
fand es sehr lustig das spiel das ich
eben auch in der psychiatrie ab sie
waren mit einem patienten spazieren und
während des spaziergangs sagte dieser
patient so ich gehe jetzt und ich möchte
mit ihnen zurück gehen und sie haben ihm
dann den weg zum bahnhof erklären ja
wusste ich das denn geschrieben ja das
war ja das war aber genauso im fall der
kam der wurde angeliefert gegen seinen
willen
und dann war ich bei diesem
aufnahmegespräch dabei und das war so
ein junger assistenzarzt ja keine ahnung
hatte und der hat dann irgendwie dieser
das waren normal kammer hat dann ihren
jeweils von johnny works erzählt und und
der arzt sagt anja dass dessen wie und
ich sag nein in usa reden alle im moment
über teile des herbstes war gerade so
mode dass man da die chinesischen
kräuter geschluckt hat und für ihn war
das schon zeichen für eine psychische
erkrankung
und dann verschwand der arzt und wir
gehen raus und mit sicherheit zu rauchen
und ich meine nicht konnte den nicht
zurückhalten der war erstens war der
überhaupt nicht verrückt der war einfach
ein bisschen auffällig gewesen
und daran habe ich mir gedacht wenn er
schon ab haut dann soll er wenigstens
den bahnhof finden was ist ihr terrain
der nacht herum und es war eine seltsame
seltsame geschichte ja es war wirklich
eine tolle 1 führung es war an einem
meiner ersten tage da und dann war ich
für den rest des praktikums an der der
den patienten
verloren hat aber sind diese geschichte
einerseits amüsant aber andererseits
eben auch sehr schön weil sie auch was
trotzdem über das schreiben und das
lesen verrät weil es ja auch offene
ausgänge auf sind die sie die sie
vorziehen und was sie auch gerade sagten
diese offenheit in der begegnung und
eben auch im schreiben und ja ich freue
mich darauf jetzt etwas zu hören wir
freuen uns darauf das wissen wir nicht
aber wir gehen davon aus
ich habe meine lesebrille nicht dabei
ich habe gedacht das wird das erste buch
bei dem ich mit lesebrille ist meistens
geht es wenn das licht gut ist also ich
versuch's mal vielleicht mache ich ein
paar fehler mehr als sonst aber
problems mal ja ich lese einfach von
anfang an darum muss ich es gar nichts
voraussagen
früher am tag hatte es ein wenig
geregnet jetzt ist der himmel nur noch
teilweise bewölkt mit kleinen kräftigen
wolken deren ränder weiß leuchten im
sonnenlicht
von hier aus ist die sonne schon nicht
mehr zu sehen sie ist in der bewaldeten
hügel kette verschwunden und es ist
spürbar kühler geworden der fluss führt
viel wasser anschwellen bildet sich
weißer schaum ist es ist mir als könne
ich die energie spüren die in bewegtem
wasser steckt als fließe sie durch mich
hindurch ein kräftiger beleben das strom
hundert meter flussaufwärts wo das
wasser über die das wer stürzt war ich
das gurgelnde geräusch einem lauten
vollen rauschen das wort rauschen trifft
es nicht es ist viel zu ungenau in
seinen vielen bedeutungen und
anwendungen alles rauscht der fluss der
regen der wind der eltern rauscht ich
muss eine akte zum thema geräusche des
wassers an ich frage mich wo in der
systematik sehen gehört natur physik
vielleicht sogar musik
geräusche gerüche licht phänomene farben
so vieles fehlen auch in meinem archiv
soviel unbeschriebenes umfasste soon
erfassbare
ich bin dem pfad entlang gegangen der
den fluss hoch führt ins tal hinein
franziska hat sich zu mir gesagt ich
weiß nicht woher sie gekommen ist
vielleicht wurde sie vom wasser
angezogen wie es uns beide immer schon
angezogen hat
plötzlich geht sie neben mir sie sagt
nichts lächelt mich nur an als ich zu
ihr hinüber schauen dieses verschmitzte
lächeln das sich nie ganz deuten konnte
und vielleicht deshalb so sehr liebe an
hier sie nicht mehr zu als wolle sie
mich an ermuntern etwas zu tun zu sagen
das haar ist die er dabei ins gesicht
gefallen sie streicht ist zurück ich
möchte meine hand auf ihren nacken legen
ihre nackten küssen ich liebe dich sage
ich ich will ihre anfassen aber ich
greife ins leere
manchmal taucht sie so unvermittelt auf
ohne dass sich an sie gedacht habe
leistet mir ein wenig gesellschaft und
verschwindet dann wie sie gekommen ist
und ich bin wieder allein
wie lange bin ich schon gegangen eine
halbe stunde eine stunde vor mir läuft
ein schwarzer käfer über den weg und ich
stehe still und beobachte ihn was für
ein käfer ist dass es gibt
hunderttausende von insektenarten und
ich kenne keinen nutzen davon
marienkäfer mai und juni käfer wanzen
asseln tausendfüßer heuschrecken bienen
und hummeln ameisen was weiß ich so
vieles fehlt mir noch
die matten fahren jetzt im frühjahr in
denen sich schon die kräftigeren des
sommers ankündigen der leichte wind der
nicht kalt ist aber auch noch nicht warm
und mich schauen lässt nicht frieren
eine wahrnehmung nur an der oberfläche
ich habe die fußgängerbrücke genommen
und bin auf den der anderen seite des
flusses zurückgegangen der weg ist etwas
breiter hier aber weniger begangen an
manchen stellen ist die erde aufgeweicht
schützen haben sich gebildet in denen
sich die hochspannungsleitung und die
wolken spiegeln
als ich mich den stadtrand nähere werden
die geräusche wieder lauter
der namenlose weg auf dem ich gehe die
schrebergärten einige schon vorbereitet
für die frühlings bepflanzung andere
noch im winterschlaf und einige ganz
verwahrlost vermutlich seit jahren nicht
bestellt
dahinter die bahnlinie und etwas weiter
entfernt die autobahn
das rauschen des flusses das rauschen
der autos der lkws ein hohes ziehen und
dann noch ein anderes rauschen das
metallisch klingt und pulsiert einzug
der vor über fährt wie soll das alles
beschrieben wie festgehalten werden
dass gehen hat mich müde gemacht ich bin
es nicht mehr gewohnt und habe mich
unterhalb des wehrs auf eine holzbank
gesetzt ich sitze am fluss und bin
überwältigt von der fülle der eindrücke
die auf mich einströmt es ist dieses
gefühl der klarheit und durchlässigkeit
das sich einstellt wenn man nach einer
langen krankheit zum ersten mal wieder
das haus verlässt etwas geschwächt doch
nüchtern und mit geschärften sinnen
ich schließe die augen das rauschen wird
lauter der fluss führt mehr wasser
fließt schneller er ist ockergelb es
regnet nur noch ganz leicht schließlich
hört es auf ich fresse ich trage nur
bade großen und habe ein handtuch um die
schultern geschlungen die kälte lässt
mich meinen körper deutlicher spüren als
sonst alles ist sehr klar und
oberflächlich ich empfinde ein glück
dass sich wie unglück anfühlt
ich muss an franziska denken die jetzt
bestimmt daheim ist und hausaufgaben
macht oder einen kuchen backt oder tut
was mädchen eben tun
geteilt und sein stück des schulwegs an
der großen kreuzung unserer wege sich
trennen stehen wir oft lange und reden
worüber haben wir uns damals nur immer
unterhalten der gesprächsstoff schien
uns nie auszugehen
dann schaut einer von uns auf die uhr
und merkt wie spät es schon ist und dass
unsere mütter mit dem mittagessen auf
uns warten ein lachen ein hastiger
abschied
der weg nach hause in gedanken noch
immer bei franziska ihre stimme ihr
lachen im ohr die dinge die sie sagt und
jene die sie nicht
dann das quietschen des gartenpools das
knirschen des kieses in der mittäglichen
stille das rauschen des dunstabzug die
gerüchte ja sagt kirche dringen durch
das geöffnete fenster ist das
zeitzeichen zu hören die mittags
nachrichten die stimme der mutter das
klappern eines tops im spülbecken
wenn am nachmittag eine schule war und
ich herumstreunende dachte ich oft an
franziska ich dachte nicht an sisi war
einfach da ging neben mir doch den wald
betrachtete mich bei allem was ich tat
saß mit wie am fluss und warf steine ins
wasser wie ich sie kitzelt mich mit
einem grashalm im nacken es ist wie eine
scheue liebkosung
hast du gewusst dass man sich nicht
selbst kitzeln kann sagt sie und fährt
sich mit dem grashalm über das gesicht
und gleicht mich an
weil ich verliebt in franziska
dauern hieß es in der klasse der es in
die verliebt oder din jenen die beiden
gehen miteinander
aber was bedeutet dass
meine gefühle waren viel größer viel
verwirrender als diese kindischen
pärchen spiele die ebenso schnell zu
ende gingen wie sie begonnen hatten
meine gefühle für franziska
überwältigten mich wenn ich mit ihr
zusammen war kam es mir vor als befinde
ich mich in der mitte der welt als gäbe
es nur uns beide und diesen moment und
nichts und niemanden sonst keine schule
keine eltern keine kameraden aber
franziska liebte mich nicht
ich habe das haus im winter über kaum
verlassen eigentlich habe ich es seit
jahren immer seltener verlassen seit mir
die stelle gekündigt wurde seit der
trennung von anita die keine wirkliche
trennung war
ich habe anita aufgegeben wie so vieles
in den vergangenen jahren und damit
vielleicht meine letzte chance sein
normales leben zu führen ein leben wie
es von einem erwartet wird aber
niemand erwartet noch etwas von mir ich
selbst am allerwenigsten
und so habe ich mich nach und nach immer
mehr zurückgezogen
an manchen tagen bin ich nur im freien
wenn ich zum briefkasten oder in den
garten um frische luft zu schnappen ein
oder zweimal die woche kaufe ich im
kleinen lebensmittelgeschäft hier im
viertel ein kurz vor ladenschluss wenn
selten andere kunden das in
dort beschafft ich mir das wenige was
ich brauche und bin jedes mal dankbar
wenn der ladenbesitzer mich grüßt als
sehr mich zum ersten mal
was sich im laden ich kriege bestelle
ich aus katalogen oder im internet
ich liebe die menschenleere
zweidimensionale welt der online shops
die sterilen produktbilder auf weißem
grund vorderansicht rückansicht zeiten
an sich ja einkaufswagen
ich gehe zur bank wenn wir das bargeld
aus geht zum friseur
wenn meine haare sich gar nicht mehr
bändigen lassen weil ich zum letzten mal
bei einem arzt verweise ich nicht mehr
aber es ist lange her
die meiste zeit verbringe ich damit die
zeitungen und zeitschriften durch zu
arbeiten die ich abonniert habe die
relevanten artikel auszuschneiden und
aufzukleben zu kodieren und in die
entsprechenden akten einzuordnen die
arbeit für die ich früher bezahlt wurde
und die ich seit meiner entlassung für
mich alleine weiterführen weil ich nicht
weiß wie sonst meine zeit verbringen
soll
auch wenn alle sagen das archiv werde
nicht mehr gebraucht es sei ein
anachronismus in zeiten der datenbanken
und der volltextsuche
warum taten sie sich meine chefs dann so
schwer damit mir das archiv zu
überlassen die entscheidung alles
wegzuwerfen war schnell getroffen von
irgendeinem geschäftsleitungsmitglied
einem jener dynamischen typen die leute
wie ich nur bei der jährlichen
weihnachtsfeier aus der ferne zu sehen
bekam
da war als ich vorschlug das ganze
archiv inklusive des fahrbaren regal
systems zu übernehmen und in meinem
keller unterzubringen wurde die
geschäftslage misstrauisch und rang
wochenlang mit der entscheidung mein
direkter vorgesetzter brachte alle
möglichen einwände vor das sei doch viel
zu teuer um ein haus überhaupt das
gewicht der akten aushalte ob die
feuerwehr es erlaube eine so große menge
papier in einem privathaus zu lagern
ich hatte geld genug und versprach für
die kosten des umzugs aufzukommen mein
keller war groß und hatte betonierten
böden die das gewicht problemlos tragen
konnten bei der feuerwehr schien man gar
nicht zu verstehen was die bedenken
waren wenn sie wüssten was die leute
alles in ihren kellern und auf ihren
dachböden lagern sagte da man am telefon
und lachte sein lachen hatte einen
unangenehmen unterton als teile er ein
schmutziges geheimnis mit mir
selbst nachdem ich vor meinen chef alle
einwände entkräftet hatte dauert es noch
einmal wochen bis man sich endlich dazu
durchgerungen hatte mir das papier
archiv in meine hände zu geben
es wurde ein komplizierter vertrag
ausgearbeitet in dem es um urheberrechte
und um persönlichkeitsschutz ging und in
dem geregelt wurde dass sich das archiv
wieder zu kommerziellen zwecken nutzen
noch weiter veräußern dürfe
die unterzeichnung des schriftstücks war
die einzige gelegenheit bei der ich dem
zuständigen mann aus der
geschäftsleitung begegnete und ich sah
ihm an dass er mich für einen spinner
hielt was mich in meinem vorhaben nur
noch mehr bestärkte
diese leute haben den wahren zweck des
archivs nie begriffen sie haben nur die
kosten gesehen und sie doch die anzahl
der rechercheaufträge geteilt und
gemerkt dass sich nicht auszahlt
aber was zahlt sich schon aus das archiv
verweist nicht nur auf die welt ist ein
abbild der welt eine welt für sich und
im gegensatz zur realen welt hat es eine
ordnung alles hat seinen festgelegten
platz und kann mit etwas übung jederzeit
schnell gefunden werden das ist der
wahre zweck des archivs da zu sein und
ordnung zu schaffen
der einbau der regale in meinem keller
wurde durch eine spezialisierte firma
ausgeführt die den boden auf meißelte
und die schienen verlegt der
ohrenbetäubende lärm des
presslufthammers erfüllte das haus der
staub drang bis herauf in die wohnräume
ein feiner nebel in dem die strahlen des
sonnenlichts hervortraten das weiße
licht des aufbruchs
dann kam endlich der große tag an dem
ein laster von meinem haus hielt und
packer stöhnend und fluchend die kisten
mit akten in meinem keller schleppten
ich erschrak ein wenig als ich sah wie
viele kisten es waren wie viel material
das nur mir gehört und für das sich die
verantwortung trug
die aufregung des umbaus und des umzugs
war so groß dass ich erst einmal ein
paar tage brauchte um wieder zu mir zu
kommen
das einräumen der akten war dann wie ein
langsamer heilungsprozess die ordnung
wiederherzustellen und schließlich alles
an seinem platz zu wissen
glaubt mal bis hier her würde ich sagen
ja
vielen dank
ihr protagonist ist ein archivar er
liebt die ordnung wie sind sie auf
diesen beruf der jetzt erst mal
vielleicht nicht so wahnsinnig spannend
klingt warum haben sie einen archivar
als protagonisten gesehen
ich habe den schon länger im kopf warum
kann ich nicht so genau sagen aber es
ist ich habe ja auch
lange das thema
fiktion realität ist ja kommt ja
eigentlich in fast allen meinen büchern
vor und da geht es immer darum wer macht
fiktion und und bücher sind fiktion
80 der chronische planes infektion
builders infektionen und im grunde ist
auch eine archiv eine fiktion also der
versuch irgendwie die welt
abzubilden in einem archiv der ja aber
eigentlich hoffnungslos ist und trotzdem
immer wieder versucht wird also habe ich
immer fasziniert auch bibliotheken zum
beispiel ich bin auf den bibliotheken
und und einerseits diese unglaubliche
fülle an material und aber auch dieses
gefühl dass das ja alles nicht genügt
das ist ja viel zu wenig ist und
das hat mich immer fasziniert und
vielleicht kommt daher der archivar ich
habe auch mal einen freund gehabt ja in
summe salz und nicht gearbeitet hat aber
das war vor
30 40 jahren man könnte auch sagen dass
das archiv jetzt in ihrem roman dient es
ja auch als als rückzugsort als ort des
haltes wo eben die ordnung da ist die im
leben offenbar vermisst wird
was sozusagen man könnte auch sagen
dieser mann hat etwas gefunden was was
ihm wirklich liegt und was ihn glücklich
macht und andererseits ist da das würde
ja sehr deutlich diese diese fiktion und
und und und die vorstellung da ist diese
frau die die ja noch liebt an die er
sich erinnert hier nur ein einziges mal
küssen durfte und ihm dann sagte ich ich
liebe dich nicht
wieso zu sagen warum scheitert er in
diesem archiv dieses archiv nicht als
burg zu bauen die die liebe dann draußen
hält ich glaube wenn er ein wirklich
leidenschaftlicher arriva wäre dann
würde das vielleicht machen dann wäre
aber nicht interessant für mich also er
muss für mich muss ja auch zweifel an
diesem archiv er muss ja auch spüren das
ist eben nicht genügt das ist eben also
wer archiviert tötet ja auch das ja wenn
nabokov seine schmetterlinge sammelt
oder war es nach prokop jünger hand
insekten gesammelt oder
das heißt ja immer auch töten damit man
sie sammeln kann und im grunde es kommt
ja auch vor diese sache ist natürlich
auch tot weil weil
ich weiß hat die faz noch ein archiv ja
ja und ich habe auch nicht vor dieses
archiv zu kaufen ja das kann ich noch
gar nicht leisten aber das gibt also
auch hier es gibt das ja ja wir haben
noch papiere tatsächlich und auch also
nicht nur die eigenen erzeugnisse
sondern auch anderer zeuge okay weil in
der schweiz werden die eigentlich
weitgehend aufgelöst live es gibt noch
so ein zentrales das ist aber noch
elektronisch und und eben das ist ja
auch andere welt jan bekommt einmal wie
eine altmodische welt vor aber hat eben
so zu sagen ja auch seine berechtigung
und und wichtigkeit sein oder
also ich war damals nicht als er
analoger menschen sind die jetzt auf das
analoge aber ich habe damals als ich in
windeln nach riefen auch zum teil
gearbeitet habe als ich noch
journalistisch gearbeitet habe ist mir
danach oft aufgefallen wie viele davon
auch abgeschrieben ist also wie
das da waren 100 artikeln über an den
figuren man merkte er waren die drei die
substanz hat man alle anderen wagen
waren im grunde kombination von von den
anderen artikel die auch da waren als es
das leben ist eben immer ein bisschen
komplett komplizierter als ein
zeitungsartikel und und das merkt ja
auch ist es ja eben keine
wissenschaftliche bibliothek sondern es
ist im grunde genommen sind sie einfach
zeitungsbericht die dir da sammeln
das bild des mannes dass sie entwerfen
ich habe in einer rezension gelesen
männer dämmerung dass sie gerne so eine
demontage des eigenen geschlechts
betreiben würden die männer bei ihnen
immer so ein bisschen ja so ein bisschen
looser haft schwachsinn ich muss sagen
ich habe dass er lese es anders aber ich
fand sozusagen diese diese beobachtung
interessant und ich würde sie gern würde
gerne von ihnen wissen können sie damit
irgendetwas anfangen mit dieser männer
dämmerung oder ist zum einen muss ich
sagen ich kenne die journalistin seit 30
jahren das ist eine lustige person ist
sie sich mal diese aber da hat sie sich
ein bisschen es gibt ja mal so ich weiß
nicht ob sie das auch machen wo man
denkt es muss jetzt eine these her und
man liest was und dann muss das
irgendwie schaffe das ist natürlich
trends man muss dann beim letzten roman
also weit über das land war das da hat
einer geschriebene sein anti
feministisches manifest
weil und zwar als einzigen gründe weil
die frauen hausfrau war als gelb ist
keine hausfrauen auf der welt aber
einfach ich habe ja nicht gesagt alle
frauen sollen hausfrauen seien aber und
und diesmal war es halt gegen die männer
ich das geht so ein bisschen an mir
vorbei also ich habe mich amüsiert
darüber aber es ich habe nicht wirklich
mein buch darin gesehen ehrlich gesagt
sie selbst haben ja in ihrer karriere in
ihrer laufbahn ist flug flugzeuge
enteisen würde ich jetzt nicht zur
karriere zählen aber sie haben flugzeuge
enteist und haben auch mal gesagt das
sei ebenso ein männer ding aber die
männer bei ihnen dürfen eben keine
flugzeuge es stimmt das dürfen sie nicht
und auch kein holz hacken ohne ja ja das
ist das was ich glaube schon dass männer
mögen so nicht alle aber viele satz man
fühlt man sich so irgendwie ja so im
sturm oder segeln oder irgendwas mit mit
wind im gesicht oder so das ist das fand
ich immer ganz toll auch weil ich in der
zeit eigentlich relativ langweiligen
bürojob hatte und immer wenn es anfängt
zu schneiden aber ich kaufe die ruf mich
ist wir brauchen
das viel stärker
als die buchhaltung machen
aber was war die frage beschuldigungen
um die aber um eine mensa sie nicht
dürfen
dürfen die das nie
ich habe noch keinen entdeckt oder im
flugzeug enteist vielleicht eine gute
idee für den nächsten roman das ist ja
kennen sich doch auch gut aus also
wandern gehen die zum teil die gehen ja
schon raus naja spaziert natürlich so
ein bisschen der in wahrheit über das
land wirbt der
der der der wandert aber hier unser
namenlose ich erzähler und es geht an
den spaziergängen es gibt eine erzählung
von einem der so hüllen höhe forschung
macht ja das geht schon in die
entbehrungsreiche ein bisschen
aber ich kann daran arbeiten
ein verlag schon christoph ransmayr für
die für die outdoor sachen den 3 besser
also ich mich ja nicht konkurrenzieren
dann dürft ihr die kritikerin die ihnen
damals vorgeworfen hat ein anti
feministische statiker man kritiker ok
vorgeworfen hat sich jetzt freuen weil
die frau in ihrem jetzigen roman ist ja
eine starke frau franz der franziska
fabienne die ihr künstlername lautet ist
schlagersängerin geht ihren weg macht
karriere hat verschiedene beziehungen er
ließ davon immer nur in der zeitung ist
immer froh wenn sich wieder trennt von
den fußballspieler produzenten und
wieder single ist
die baby ist sozusagen diese diese
starke frau auch eine figur die sie
immer wieder gerne jetzt neben der
hausrat natürlich die auch eine starke
frau mit stadt natürlich absolut
vorkommen lassen oder ist sozusagen an
das vom krieg ist sie schwäche die man
indem man sieht verkennt man ihn
eigentlich und ist eigentlich eine
stärke und diese starke frau ist gar
nicht so stark wie sehr scheint für das
glaube ich nicht obschon also aber ich
hab' ich glaube einfach dass ist so also
in meiner lebenserfahrung ich sehe viele
starke fahren und viele schwache männer
und ich hab mal die andere in meinem
allerersten buch was noch vor agnes
rauskam das war so eine gelegenheit
sting
habe ich das schon geschrieben dass er
im grunde genommen das beats und stilles
übereinkommen die frauen tun so als
wären die männer der statik schlecht
dafür dürfen die männer sprach sein und
es ist einfach eine lebenserfahrung ich
kenne so viele beziehungen wo
wirklich die frauen
das zusammenhalten wo die frauen die
stärkeren sind wo sie wo sie
realistischer auch sind
also von daher würde ich sagen das ist
einfach realismus das ist gar nicht dass
kein programm oder so die weltwoche hat
sich immer ein frauenversteher genannt
würde sich damit
identifizieren sie auch mal gesagt dass
sie frauen einfach irgendwie
interessanter finden ja ist ja
naheliegend weil
also wenn es nicht menschen verstehen
schöner weil weil immer in meinem
nächsten buch ich werde jetzt nicht
herauslesen dass sind die noch geheim
aber aber da sagt er irgendwann auf die
frage wer wird da wird viel mehr gemacht
über den autor gibson autor da kommt
dann die frage warum eben wegen warum
eine frau und schreiben das als getan
nur frauen und männer soll ich denn über
kaninchen schreiben
und es ist natürlich schon so ich meine
männer frauen kinder
landschaften landschaften ja aber ich
war frauen verstehe ich weiß es nicht
gibt es denn so wenige autos machen die
frauenversteher weiß ich nicht ich fand
auch ihre antwort eben interessant weil
sie sagten dass sie also vielleicht ist
schon ich weiß nicht mehr ausweichen
jahres interview stand aber ich fand es
ganz lustig weil sie ihm sagte na ja am
anfang dachten sie sie müssen irgendwie
besonders cool sein und irgendwie
vielleicht auch so leicht arrogant und
haben dann gemerkt dass man frauen aber
ganz anders erobert nämlich indem man
sie zum lachen bringt und ihnen zuhört
und dass ich die meisten wenn dann nur
für autos interessieren würden wäre das
eigentlich so ganz ganz easy und da
dachte ich okay fügte
konzept interessant aber das war jetzt
ein leicht hände zusammen
nein so war sie aber ich weiß ja aber
ich habe schon gemerkt und das machen ja
junge männer rach das ja oft falsch dass
sie versuchen frauen zu beeindrucken
indem sie in den kopf voll quatschen und
das habe ich schon gemerkt man muss
zuhören nicht quatschen
als das ist viel viel attraktiver wenn
man wenn man einfach den menschen
gegenüber wahrnimmt und nicht sich
aufplustert die filme machen das ja gern
die dvu schlagen hier rat oder die
männer mit ihren coolen autos oder was
weiß ich oder eben holz hacken oder oder
aber im grunde genommen ich glaube was
gute beziehung ausmacht ist ja nicht das
einer cool ist sondern dass die
miteinander kommunizieren
absolut und die empathie spielt ja auch
in ihren büchern eine große rolle
und sie sagten ja auch mal sie würden
hätten keine besonders gute
menschenkenntnis aber sie seien ein sehr
empathischer mensch ja das glaube ich
wirklich ich habe herrn geradezu
besucher am sonntag
bei leuten und dann hab ich so gesagt
das war ja nett und und dann hat meine
freundin hat daten hatte ich sofort viel
viel genauer gesehen was da was da war
also und und ich hab ich bin jemand der
dann einfach dass ich dinge aus denkt
oder der sich inspirieren lässt von von
situation aber aber ich bin nicht der
der einen klaren blick hat
ich glaube fantasie ist er ein gegner
von menschenkenntnis die die leute die
am besten menschen beurteilen konnten
die ich kannte waren immer leute mit
wenig fantasie weil die einfach die
realität gesehen haben
ok
muss ich noch mal drüber nacht
noch mal noch mal zu ihrem buch das das
archiv der gefühle sie haben das ja
während der pandemie geschrieben die
pandemie spielt ja in dem buch gar keine
rolle bekommt aber vor hat die pandemie
ihr schreiben beflügelt oder inwiefern
spiegelt sich das wider in ihrem text
also beflügelt in einem sinne indem ich
einfach sehr viel mehr zeit zum
schreiben gehabt aber ich sehr viel
weniger lesung gehabt habe das war
einfach also ich habe jetzt in zwei
jahren pandemie habe ich zwei bücher
mehr oder weniger fertig geschrieben das
hätte ich vorher hätte ich dafür 34
jahre gebraucht
und dann war es einfach so sie hat halt
stattgefunden ich schreibe immer aus der
gegenwart heraus
und von daher war sie einfach da wie sie
sagen hintergrund dass es war nicht das
thema aber die bald da und darum ist sie
auch mein buch da aber sie wird ja nie
nie erwähnt es wird nie erwähnt aber man
merkt das an so kleinen detail was
bezahlen
ja genau ja ich war ich hätte künstlich
gefunden dass da irgendwie aus zu lassen
wobei in dem nächsten buch kommt sie
jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr vorrätig fand
das hat das reicht mir jetzt also das
reicht uns allen vermutlich
aber
ich finde es ganz schön wenn wenn ein
buch also ein buch weg sein so eine art
sowie ein biotop das wechseln der zeit
und das ist oft auch so ich glaube wenn
ich ein buch im winter schreibe jetzt
ein anderes als wenn ich im sommer
schreibe einfach weil die gegenwart
immer mit einfließt ins buch und wenn
ich sehr nah pandemie schreibe ist es
ein anderes buch als wenig störend einer
anderen zeit schreibe aber war die
pandemie für sie dann etwas bedrückendes
oder eher etwas
bedrückt nein ich nicht also nein nein
ich nicht nein ich habe relativ schnell
wieder gut ich bin sowieso relativ
resistent nicht gegen viren aber gegen
gegen äußere einflüsse
von daher ich habe glaube ich eine woche
lang hat mir das so ein bisschen sorgen
gemacht und dann im gegenteil dann ist
das schreiben wie so ein rückzugsort wo
man dann sich aufs schreiben
konzentrieren kann und dann ist die
pandemie weit weg und und ich habe auch
genug platz zu hause und so meine kinder
sind waren in der situation wo es ja
auch nicht allzu sehr betroffen hat sie
waren beide so einer guten phase gerade
in der ausbildung
und von daher war sitzt nicht also ich
bin kein opfer der pandemie und
auch natürlich gerade bei autoren es
gibt ja viele die jetzt sagen ihr erstes
buch hatten für die war es schwer weil
die haben jetzt diesen diesen star nicht
gehabt aber wenn ich bin jetzt wieder 20
jahre lang rom gereisten tab ganz viele
lesung gemacht da war es irgendwie was
zu in the jackal maria ninja oder zwei
jahre weniger zu machen
wenn wenn sie schreiben
lassen sie sich treiben also sie haben
keinen plan vorher
ist das sozusagen nicht auch so ein
bisschen beängstigend oder vertrauen sie
da ganz ihrem
instinkt oder ihrem talent
beängstigende würde ich nicht sagen es
ist es ist risiko halt aber risiko macht
ja auch spaß also ich bin nie jemand
gewesen der mit einem gummiseil um die
beine von der staumauer gesprungen ist
oder solche sachen gemacht hat aber beim
schreiben mag ich schon ein gewisses
risiko
ich habe beim nächsten buch habe ich
irgendwann nach einem drittel des buches
gesagt lass ich meine hauptfigur sterben
einfach um mich selbst herauszufordern
was mache ich jetzt wenn er plötzlich
weg ist und das macht das macht spaß
jetzt war eine alles nennen sie ihre
figuren ja ja ja gut ihr mann sie hat
jeder das war jetzt nicht ich habe ihn
nicht umgebracht das ist natürlich alles
gestorben
aber
so ein bisschen den einsatz zu erhöhen
das macht schon spaß einschreiten auch
sich selber hürden in den weg zu legen
oder schwieriger zu machen wie war das
haben beim archiv der gefühle wo sind da
würden aufgetreten
weiß ich jetzt gar nicht aber was war es
schon immer eine frage war ist war immer
trifft der franziskaner trieb sie nicht
und ich
fand dann ja man der musik das kann
nicht sein dass er das ganze buch sie
immer nur erinnert und und und sie
praktisch in seiner hand das sie
auftreten lässt die die müssen auch
irgendwann mal zusammenkommen aber
wie schafft man das dass es nicht
kitschig werden
und das war so eine schwierigkeit und
das andere vielleicht schon das was sie
gesagt haben der ist ja nicht an sich
ein interessanter mensch also wie sie
schreiben also ein menschen dass er
trotzdem interessant wird
ja müsste ich mich damit sie jetzt
länger darüber nachdenken können wir
vielleicht morgen noch mal sagen frage
noch mal
ich finde ich muss jetzt mal ganz kurz
suchen entschuldigen ich habe irgendwie
zitat aufgeschrieben aus dem buch und
zwar heißt es einmal sagte er ich
erzähler hatte ich den alltag mit
franziska teilen wollen oder braucht ich
sie nicht viel mehr als das was sie mir
ein leben lang gewesen war eine
unerreichbare liebe eine sehnsucht das
ist ja genau das was jetzt gerade
ansprechen dass der
ich-erzähler eben auch nicht so recht
weiß ist es sozusagen ist nicht
eigentlich dieser zustand der sehnsucht
der perfekte zustand weil die realität
diese sehnsucht nie übertreffen ja ja ja
ja das ist ein thema das mich schon
lange interessiert
ich habe schon mal erzählung geschrieben
die ist wie sieht denn das experiment
genau
wo ein pärchen zusammenlebt und aber nie
sex hat weil sie sagen im grunde
genommen in dem moment wo wir sex haben
ist wieder zauber weg weil dann werden
wir zusammen war und dann wird es auch
irgendwann weniger die spannung auch
nachlassen und und das ist da eher
humorvoll vielleicht nicht gerade aber
es ist auf jeden fall nicht so ganz
ernst gemeint aber im grunde geht es
hier noch mal um dasselbe und ich habe
auch gesagt das ist bei nonnen die sind
ja mit mit jesus verheiratet und dass
diese sich der ideale mann weil er nie
da ist und der der kann eine auch nie
enttäuschen weil er weil er nie aber er
spricht naja gut mit manchen sprich das
spricht ja schon
irgendwie vor ihre man sich wie man es
gerne hätte vielleicht nein aber das ist
schon diese diese fantasiefigur nicht
ich würde mich auch fand ich auch immer
eine spannende vorstellung was geschehen
würde wenn man all diese männer die den
pirelli-kalender aufgehängt haben oder
pamela anderson was die sagen würden
wenn mal pamela anderson einer tür
klingelt wird und sein würde also gehen
wir mal einen kaffee trinken oder
das würden die vermutlich gar nicht
wollen also es gibt so
jamann ich meine wir haben so unsere
fantasien aber im grunde sind die
phantasien nicht besser als die
wirklichkeit aber sie müssen jetzt nicht
zwingend vermischt werden fantasien
müssen sich nicht unbedingt in dem buch
ist es ja so dass diese fantasie aber
natürlich so stark ist und diese
sehnsucht so stark ist dass ihr
irgendwann zum handeln bewegt ja und
dass dieser schritt gegangen wird und
das ist ja auch das schöne dass man wenn
die fantasie sehr stark ist oder die
sehnsucht sehr stark ist man doch
irgendwann überprüfen möchte hält die
realität diesem geschehen dann ja weil
er glaube ich einfach in dem fall es ist
ja auch nicht mehr einlassen also das
ist ja eine frau die mal in seinem leben
eine rolle gespielt hat also die mal
realität war und dann halt immer mehr
zur fiktion geworden ist und von daher
natürlich würde ich mir das auch
wünschen dass man eben mindestens das
überprüft und halt schaut und sich dem
aussetzt und sie wird ja auch in dem
moment wo sie dann endlich trifft
als die hat inzwischen einen
künstlernamen und da akzeptierte ja auch
erst das jeden nicht mehr seine
franziska ist sondern verlieren also die
die schlagersängerin also dass
eigentlich die frau die er sein leben
lang angehimmelt hat im grunde nicht
mehr existiert und das ist jetzt eine
ganz neue geschichte wird es diese
begegnung mit mit fabienne wird dann
eben im grunde
ein neuanfang
diese verschmelzung von liebespaaren ist
ja für sie was ich gut verstehen kann
etwas sehr große ligges weil sie sagen
dass die der ware zauber in der
fremdheit und darin liegt sich immer
wieder einander anzunähern ist das
spielt es in dem buch eben auch eine
rolle also dieses erste gedanklich sich
annähern und dann tatsächlich den
schritt wagen
oder es ist ja schon zuviel these
ich finde es schön wenn jeder ein buch
so liest wie wir es gerne lesen möchte
und und auch im besten fall die auch was
für sich selber herausliest was für ihn
ehren die
an mehr wert ist oder wie soll man es
nennen
[Musik]
es ist vielleicht auch ein spiel dabei
also eben nicht jede fantasie muss
realisiert werden aber es ist natürlich
dann schon spannend auch mal fantasien
zu überprüfen und zu schauen und es ist
wirklich schon so ich war immer ein
großer obwohl ich einen davon lebe
fiktionen zu verkaufen ein großer
verehrer der realität also ich auch wenn
ich zum beispiel recherchiere ich finde
ich muss an die orte hin nicht muss ich
kann nur literatur aus ausleben machen
mich aus anderer literatur
und die realität ist immer viel reicher
als einbruch weil es recht weil das
anfassen kann weil
kommt immer ganz viel weil das buch ist
im grunde nur ein behelf das ist nicht
das wahre weil sie jetzt realität sagen
sie
betreiben ja kein autobiografisches
schreiben wie es jetzt gerade eben sehr
populär ist und dass sehr viele
literaten ton und natürlich fließt aber
ihr leben oder fliegen ihre erfahrungen
spielen spielen noch alle und fließen
mit ein man kann das jetzt sicherlich
nicht so prozentual sagen aber welche
rolle spielt das autobiografische sie
verschwindend gering oder
ich hab mal ich hab mal so ein arzt
roman paul die gemachten da stand dann
hinten drin so die zusammensetzung so
ich ein lebensmittel da stand ja die
fünf weniger als 5% witze
20% haushaltgeräte
können wir mit dem verladen wird
dekoration machen 30 prozent der
autobiografisch 20 prozent recherchiert
nein es ist auch wieder mein nächster
roman da konnte ich die frage auch vor
eben das ist auch ein autor der da
spricht und der sagt irgendwann was
hätte ich davon
autobiografisch zu schreiben eigentlich
nichts ich mache mir nur probleme also
der der beste grund gegensatz zu
begreifen ist das ist überhaupt nichts
bringt weil ich bin ja nicht
schweinsteiger wenn ich jetzt ein
fußballer der ein berühmter dann würden
sie alle wissen wollen wie ich lebe und
was mein leben war aber ich bin einfach
der typ der bücher schreibt und und
darum ist es im grunde für die leser
absolut die relevant was davon
autobiografisches und darum ich verwende
material aus meinem leben aber genau so
frei wie ich anderes material verwendet
also ich ändere das ab ich ich von daher
ist es für mich gar nicht wirklich eine
frage ich mich natürlich haben eine
erfahrungsschatz den ich ausbeute aber
aber nie so dass ich sage ich erzähle
ist die wahrheit über meine beziehung zu
seinen eltern oder oder was weiß ich
weil sie gerade sagten wenn sie
bestimmte orte beschreiben oder gegen
den landschaften dann bewegen sie sich
auch in diesen landschaften ihnen dann
gerecht zu werden könnte man jetzt auch
sagen na ja aber das wäre ja dann auch
etwas was sie in der fantasie gestalten
könnten oder brauchen sie die
anschließend das für mich die realität
eben
immer immer im grunde echter war als die
literatur sich muss wenn ich einen ort
beschreiben muss ich den kennen und ich
muss wissen auch wenn das gar nicht im
text vorkommt wie ist da riecht wie es
sich anfühlt wie das wetter ist ich
profitiere ich wollte natürlich die orte
auch aus also ich gehe dann auch in
oder kandy und und die orte geben wir
auch was was in meiner fantasie
sich mir nie ausgedacht hätte also von
daher die realität schenkt auch
unglaublich viel
als dass wenn ich jetzt in meinem
nächsten buch kommt eine pfarrerin vor
dann gehe ich halt so sprechen pfarrerin
und dann sagt irgendwas was ich brauchen
kann ich habe ja auch eine pfarrerin
ausdenken können aber aber es
ist ja material ist ja da warum soll es
nicht nutzen absolut und das sind ja
dann auch die geschichten die man aus im
leben erfährt die man sich sozusagen gar
nicht so zusammen fantasieren kann dass
sie dann ja auch eine gewisse
wahrhaftigkeit aber ausstrahlen und man
beim lesen irgendwie in dem text
verschwindet und und unsere eingezogen
wird weil man sich vorstellen kann ja
das
ja wir sind einfach ich weiß ich damals
als ich es geschrieben habt da ging es
darum dass sie ein kind verliert und
dann habe ich einen
arzt angerufen ich das sagen habe ich
dir mein damaliger
hausarzt und habe ihn darüber aus
gefragt wie das wie das genau geht und
so und dann hat er das wort kind
material benutzt hat gesagt da muss das
kind material muss dann entfernt werden
und so ein wort das wäre ja nie
eingefallen und solche sachen solche
geschenke krieg mal recherchieren dinge
die die man sich nicht hätte ausdenken
können kommt die nach ihrer
journalistischen es kann gut sein ja
weil ich war nicht von natur aus so
meine kinder nerven sich oft weil ich
immer über rein gehe und ich sage aber
schauen wir mal geben wir mal rein und
wenn wir da nicht rein dürfen die sagen
uns dass schon die findet man ein und
ich konnte auch immer leute an den frack
was sie da machen und warum sie das
machen
dass das kann schon sein dass es mit dem
genesis zu tun hat ja ist ja das schöne
an dem beruf oder dass man dass man
dauernd
absolut blöde fragen stellen darf und
auch dafür bezahlen
da stand ich würde noch gerne über das
schreiben sprechen das hatte ich vorhin
kurz erwähnt war ja der erste text ihr
debüt und ihr durchbruch und da sagt sie
selbst hemingway zitieren das war der
erste texten in der ich nicht mal
peinlich gewesen ist woran haben sie das
denn gemerkt also merken sie jetzt beim
schreiben relativ schnell das geht es
gar nicht oder erst wenn es fertig ist
dann ist es wirklich so ist es nicht
mehr peinlich und ich glaube das ist
eben mehr als das es geht ja nicht darum
was drin steht in dem text sondern ich
glaube dass einige gemeint hat ist in
dem moment wo der text unabhängig vom
autor wird ist einem auch nicht nach
eigentlich egal was in den text
vorkommen
es ist schwer zu beschreiben es ist es
dann ist es eben kein persönlicher text
mehr und darum ist da dann auch nicht
autobiografisch ist selbst wenn ich was
aus mir selbst
vermutlich sogar selbst wenn ich
autobiografie schreiben würde aber aber
in dem moment wo der textur literatur
wird
trennt er sich von mir ab aber die
verbindung zu dem text bleibt auch
bestehen also anders ist immer noch ihr
text und sie haben ein bestimmtes ja es
ist mein text aber aber es ist auch
spannend beim beim immer wieder
überarbeiten
merkt man immer wer wie wieder text sich
so schließt also man merkt immer mehr
ich kann jetzt nichts mehr dran machen
und irgendwann ist der text
wie abgenabelt als ein fenster text
kannst kann zug einen guten text werden
nein und und es ist wirklich so es ist
wie wenn die oberfläche immer wenn man
vielleicht etwas schleift und es wird
immer glatter und platter und ja man
merkt man ich kann jetzt noch lange
darum schlafenden jetzt einfach weniger
aber es wird nicht mehr
hat jetzt seine form gefunden und und
dann
stelle ich das hin und das hat dann auch
mit den lesern zu tun denn ich sage dann
immer das ist auch also ich lehne den
text nicht an die leser und ich lege ihn
auch nicht an mich der der steht für
sich selbst da
und die leser und leserin kommen dann
und können mit dem machen was sie wollen
und das hat aber mit mir dann überhaupt
nichts mehr zu tun und darum kann ich
auch da wie zum beispiel interpretation
bestätigen oder oder oder denen
widersprechen weil ich sage jeder macht
mit dem text was er will und
kann ja auch ganz spannend sein für sie
wäre was liest ja natürlich je nach
eigener lebenssituation sehr entlarvend
auch also zum teil wenn man so bücher
von leuten kriegt ausgeliehen und da
sind noch so an notizen mit bleistift
drin das kann manchmal ziemlich
entlarvend sein
wenn man
erfolgreiche autoren interviews über
oder ihre bücher liest dann glaube ich
hat man das gefühl das trübt das diese
menschen gewissermaßen schon immer
erfolgreich gewesen sind aber vor jedem
erfolg liegt eben auch ein scheitern und
man vergisst ist und natürlich hatten
sie es ja auch nicht nicht nicht leicht
also sie sind ja auch
haben ihre texte ja nicht auch sofort
bei verlagen untergebracht wie war
sozusagen diese ja die zeit des
scheiterns eigentlich für sie
das ist halt die lehre die man macht
oder dass dann wenn man lernt etwas
indem man es erst mal falsch machten
dann auch mal falsch macht und es gibt
dieses berühmte zitat von beckett
was aber auch mal völlig falsch
interpretiert aber ist egal aber wie
sagt man es jeden fall wieder aufstehen
weitermachen noch mal probieren besser
besser scheitern
haben sie verstanden wenn texte
abgelehnt worden sind warum sie
abgelehnt wir sind tatsächlich also
vielleicht nicht in dem moment aber im
nachhinein muss ich sagen das war ich
hab' ich könnte keinen verlag vorwerfen
dass eine falsche entscheidung getroffen
hat bei accessoires so der wurde auch
von paar verlagen abgelehnt
aber da waren schon da kam schon
persönliche antworten also man hat schon
gemerkt die haben die qualität gesehen
aber haben halt es gibt ja auch
verschiedene gründe für fragen machen ja
nicht jedes buch was ihnen gefällt
sondern es muss auch rein passen und so
und da habe ich schon gemerkt dass das
hat jetzt eine andere qualität als das
was ich vorgeschrieben
persönliche absage ist ja trotzdem noch
eine absage hat sie das nie auch so
demotiviert dass sie dachten
vielleicht sollte ich doch nicht statt
doch
wir sind jetzt ist sie darüber hinweg
und zürich angekommen wenn ich an
astrologie glauben würde würde ich sagen
ich bin halt steinbock die sind und die
gehen so wie wenn die wände hoch ohne
anzuhalten
ich glaube ich hatte auch keine
alternative ich hätte nicht gewusst was
ich sonst machen soll pixel hat mal
gesagt peter wechsel angesagt wenn ein
besserer fußball spieler gewesen wäre
wäre nicht schriftsteller geworden wer
weiß ich kann auch nicht fußball spielen
nein ich glaube es war auch das was mir
einfach freude gemacht hat und im grunde
ist es glaube ich sowieso am besten wenn
man das macht was ein heute macht denn
dann ist man auch nicht so sehr vom
erfolg abhängig
ihre texte zeichnen sich ja durch
nüchternheit einerseits aus aber
andererseits so empfinde ich das jetzt
jedenfalls beim schwingen sie somit ist
manchmal so ein bisschen melancholisch
dann ist es aber teilweise auch auch
komisch was der also archiv der gefühle
bastelt der ich protagonist irgendwann
der ich-erzähler irgendwann so origami
figuren aus seinem zeitungs an material
und da das ihm vorher heilig waren dass
er so so abgeordnet hat wie haben sich
zu diesem stil gefunden mussten sie den
entwickeln weil sie früher so ein
bisschen mehr nebensätze affin
ich glaube stil hat auch ist eben nicht
nur was man kann so nach was man nicht
kann also von daher ist
hat das glaube ich schon auch damit zu
tun dass ich
das ist einfach meine art zuzusprechen
zu denken zu schreiben ich bin jemand
der immer gern dinge geklärt
als der reduziert der immer versucht die
essenz zu finden ich habe auch früher
zum beispiel habe ich nie für autos
interessiert aber ich kann
den unterschied zwischen einem
boxermotor und einem wankelmotor und
einem also das hat mich interessiert wie
dinge funktionieren also immer immer in
analysieren
und und dekorieren hat mich nie
interessiert
gleichzeitig analysieren sie aber was
ich als angenehm empfinde sie geben dem
leser keine lesart vor was hier viele
autoren auch tut also die liefern die
psychologische erklärung gewissermaßen
gleich mit das tun sie ja nicht nur das
ist eine bewusste entscheidung
ja oder ich habe es gelernt von anderen
autoren die schätze
dass also ich glaube auch ein text wird
umso lebendiger im kopf der leserin
leser desto mehr
einer wahrnehmung nahe kommt also ich
bin nicht der nette onkel der eine
geschichte erzählt sondern ich sage was
wahrgenommen werden kann und und die
leserinnen und leser die nehmen das mit
mir war und müssen dann im grunde
genommen selber das machen was wir ja
die ganze zeit tun also wird wir nehmen
die ganze zeit die welt um uns war und
und deuten sie auch und dieses deuten
das will ich den leser nicht abnehmen
das heißt ich sag nicht jemand ist
traurig sondern ich sag vielleicht nicht
weil sie war und ich sagt vielleicht
einfach nur tränen laufen ihr übers
gesicht und dann
kann jeder und jede entscheidend ist
jetzt eine fliege ins auge geflogen oder
ist sie traurig oder oder hat sie
schnupfen ergibt sich ja dann auch ein
bisschen aus dem kontext
ist er nicht in rechnung ja aber ich
glaube das macht den text lebendiger
denn wenn man eben selber praktisch die
ihn analysieren muss und nicht recht
bewusst analysieren aber einfach
praktisch irgendwann nimmt es war man
riecht was da ist man sieht was da ist
man hört was da ist sie beschreiben ja
auch das fand ich interessant franziska
bzw fabienne ich gar nicht wirklich also
eigentlich überhaupt nicht machen ich
weiß auch nicht wie sie aussieht
ich wollte gerade sagen sie sie plante
sie brünett wie also wie wissen sie
nicht
ich hab das auch gedacht bei dieser
stelle dich da am anfang gelesen habe
dieses tal rheintal ist ja
so ein wort und ich habe mir gedacht
jemand aus den bergen
aus rauris wir haben ja gehört schaut
uns zu da war ich auch schon gibt es ein
tolles festival
für den nächsten tagen oder für diesen
tag hatte ich was ganz anderes als für
jemanden der in hamburg und oder der da
wo ich wohne und ich habe mir gedacht
vermutlich dieses tal sieht in jedem
kopf von jedem leser und jeder leserin
völlig anders aus und gerade darum kann
es aber dann zum eigenen tal werden also
ich sag dann nicht das müsst ihr euch
jetzt vorstellen wie binntal in den
bergen sondern jeder macht sich seine
eigene stahl daraus und macht sich seine
eigene fabienne und diese dann
vermutlich so aus wie die frauen die man
verliebt war mit 16 und die man nie
gekriegt hat oder wie der mann mit 16 in
dem fall gibt ich wollte gerade sagen
der ich-erzähler weiß man auch nicht so
trägt hausschuhe würde ich mir
vorstellen bisschen fettiges haar
ja ja aber doch irgendwie ihnen gute
aber doch ein guter typ ich werde jetzt
nicht weiter
doch doch irgendwie ein guter ein guter
typ der das eben auch aktiv wird
also nicht männer dämmerung überhaupt
nicht natürlich nicht er fasst redakteur
vielleicht somit fand offen ist ja mal
raus ist bei uns die leute im
kulturradio dass die alle pantoffeln hut
nehmen und bei tagesanzeiger sogar die
redaktion die karten alle am morgen in
die reaktion und haben die schuhe
ausgezogen pantoffel angezogen
ok so ist es bei uns im moment nicht gut
wir sind auf ist aber vielleicht wenn
man wieder in die redaktion geht ich
werde das mal beobachten also ich habe
meine pantoffeln noch nicht
herausgestellt
es ist ja jetzt auch schullektüre weil
sie sagten das offene ende ist etwas was
der leser mögen menschen oder leser
nicht gerne auch so abgeschlossene
romane dann ist irgendwie fertig und man
kann entweder traurig sein weil sie sich
nicht bekommen oder hand glücklich weil
man denkt ja super happy end finde ich
schön
bringen sie die reaktionen dass die
leser sagen können sie nicht mal
irgendwie ein ende schreiben wenn immer
alles so ganz klar
das kommt nicht aber ich merke schon
natürlich gibt es laute das nicht mögen
es gibt auch heute die mögen es nicht
wenn man eben dinge offen lässt die
wollen dass ich sage welche haarfarbe
die frau hat und was für augenfarbe und
das tolle ist ja bei den büchern es gibt
so viele verschiedene und jeder findet
was was ihm was ihm gefällt und ich
meine wenn jemand kein sellerie markt
dann sage ich ihm nicht du musst jetzt
mal in sellerie essen sondern dann soll
er alte ort messen oder was auch immer
mag als das
nächste mal aufgefallen wie die leute
immer ganz vehement
und das mache ich sogar selbst so also
wenn man ein buch nicht mag kann man
nicht einfach sagen ich mag das nicht
sagen dann muss man es hassen und dann
muss man ist zerreißen und und aber im
grunde genommen könnte man ja auch
einfach sagen ich mache jetzt halt mehr
diese art von schreiben und ich mag mir
die andere art und deswegen ist die ja
nicht schlecht es gibt viele autoren von
denen ich überzeugt bin dass sie ganz
große autoren sind die ich einfach nicht
lesen mag wenn er das buch haben sie
zuletzt ja
schließlich nicht dabei aber ich hab'
ich versuche immer mal wieder ein buch
was war das ist gerade was ich gerade
weg gelegt habe also im moment habe ich
kann ja nur angefangen das glaube ich
das gefällt mir schon ein älteres all
die jahre heißt es glaube ich sagt mir
mein englisch aber seiten polen und aber
ich habe gerade 1 weg gelegt das war es
denn
wo ich einfach dachte ich glaube das ist
gut aber aber
ja irgendwie funktionieren nicht für
mich also ich bin nicht der leser für
dieses buch was in ihrer literatur ja
gar nicht vorkommt ist kitsch und ironie
ich weiß gar nicht kitsch hoffentlich
nicht ironie hoffte ich schon aber
wurden sie gibt es hier eine kitschige
stelle in diesen kleidern und es gab es
gab einen kritiker in der schweiz der
hat mir über drei bücher jedes mal
wieder vorgeworfen nicht kitschig und
das fand ich schon sehr lustig nein ich
fand es nicht lustig aber aber es war
lustig
also ist unter kitsch verstehe ich
rosamunde media ist ja aber es ist ja
schon spiel zum teil
also große gefühle können ja schnell
kippen ins in den kitsch und ich weiß
ich habe in der einen woche war ein tag
wie diesen
da hat das glaube ich noch nicht gesagt
aber egal und das endet ja mit einem
liebespaar bei sonnenuntergang am meer
also dass das kitschige bild überhaupt
und und das ist aber auch eine
herausforderung wie mache ich das ohne
dass es kitschig wird aber nur der nur
die situation muss ja noch kein kitsch
daneben aber ich meine sich so dieses
damit spielen mit großen gefühlen auch
spielen das finde ich schon spannend das
von daher ich finde man kann daran gehen
soll natürlich nicht kitschig werden
ironie ironie ist natürlich immer
distanz
und das wollte ich nie in mein bett
holte die distanz haben zu meinen
figuren ich habe ja lange satire und
auch geschrieben und ich hoffe ich
glaube die waren schon ironisch und ich
habe aber mein nächstes buch glaube ich
wirklich
kriege die wahl von meinem nächsten buch
aber das ist mir im moment näher als das
hier das ist glaube ich wirklich
lustiger viel lustiger als meine
bisherigen bücher und da habe ich sie
haben die geschah also es geht immer
darum wie schaffe ich es distanz zu
haben und trotzdem nahe zu sein
und ich glaube in dem fall ist es
einfach eine figur lustig ist also ich
bin nach meiner figur also ich hab die
nähe aber sie hat sie nicht dass sie ist
jemand der die welt sehr aus einer
gewissen distanz sieht und und nicht so
ganz ernst nimmt und es hat sehr viel
spaß gemacht es zu schreiben
ok dann hören wir aber jetzt nochmal
eine stelle aus ihrem aktuellen buch
genau und jetzt bin ich mir gar nicht
mehr sicher wenn ich lesen soll
jetzt dürfen sie entscheide ja ja ich
lese vielleicht dann doch die zweite
variante gar nicht so viel über über die
über die handlung gesagt von da ist
vielleicht besser nicht jetzt nicht ein
allzu großen sprung macht
also im grunde muss ich gar nichts sagen
weil sie zwar sind ein paar seiten
dazwischen aber
da passiert nicht viel
mein studium zog sich in die länge ohne
dass ich recht sagen könnte weshalb ich
war tat meine zeit ohne viel zu
erreichen oder zu unternehmen franziska
hat eine stelle haben wir das
universitätskrankenhaus angenommen und
wir trafen uns wieder häufiger
beginnen zu konzerten oder ins kino
redeten halbe nächte durch aber nie
sprachen wir über beziehungen es war als
seien wir beide noch nicht bereit dafür
franziska kam mir viel erwachsener vor
als ich mir selbst sie wohnt in einem
kleinen studio und hatte sich einen
gebrauchtwagen gekauft eine ente mit der
sie halsbrecherische fahrten unternahm
dann und wann hat es die konzerte auf
kleinen bühnen in der provinz ich fuhr
sie in ihrem auto in half ihr beim
aufbau kümmerte mich manchmal sogar um
die rudimentäre tontechnik oder
kontrollierte die eintrittskarten und
fuhr sie spät nachts wenn sie noch ganz
beseelt war von ihrem auftritt wieder
nach hause
wenn jemand aus dem publikum
aufdringlich wurde mischte ich mich ein
und hielt die leute auf distanz während
franziska in der garderobe verschwand
fanden die konzerte zu weit von zu hause
statt übernachteten wir in einfachen
hotels oder pensionen es kam sogar vor
dass wir um geld zu sparen im selben
zimmer schliefen wie bruder und
schwester
der veranstalter hatte uns den schlüssel
mitgebracht weil der gasthof nur bis
zehn uhr abends geöffnet hatte das war
irgendwo in süddeutschland im
schwarzwald glaube ich obwohl er uns den
weg genau beschrieben hatte brauchten
wir lange bis wir den ort mitten im wald
gefunden hatten es war eine wirtschaft
mit einem großen etwas
heruntergekommenen biergarten und ein
paar wenigen zimmern über der gaststube
der nacht eingang war auf der rückseite
des gebäudes hier fanden den
lichtschalter nicht und tasten und die
treppe hoch
franziska nahm ich bei der hand und ging
voraus ich musste an hänsel und gretel
denken die sich im wald verlaufen
nein sagt franziska wir sind brüderlein
und schwesterlein das brüderlein
verwandelt sich in ein reh und immer
wenn die hörner zur jagd blasen will es
in den wald es wird zur jagd dabei ist
es das gejagte und dann wird es
verwundet und kann doch nicht anders und
muss am nächsten tag wieder zur jagd ist
das nicht schön und fürchterlich
zugleich
du hast dich immer vor der jagd
gefürchtet sagt sie nicht wahr ich bin
das brüderlein und schwesterlein
und lacht ihr lachen das mich ganz
schwindelig macht
die zimmereinrichtung war endlich um den
schlechten zustand es gab nur ein großes
bett ein durchgesessenen sofa das aussah
als sei es vom sperrmüll und eine
kommode mit spiegel die heizung war
herum heruntergedreht es war feucht und
kalt im zimmer und es war auch seltsam
franziska fand alles sehr lustig obwohl
es eher deprimierend war sie machte
witze und lachte die ganze zeit die
küsterin obwohl wird ziemlich sicher die
einzigen gäste waren vermutlich die
einzigen menschen im gebäude
vielleicht gibt es hier wölfe sagte
franziska und schaute mich mit großen
augen an ich glaube sie war etwas
betrunken
warum hast du so große augen fragte ich
damit ich besser sehen kann und warum
hast du so einen großen mund fragte sie
und blinzelte mir zu
wir hatten eine angefangene flasche
rotwein aus dem konzertlokal mitgebracht
im bad fanden wir zwar in plastikfolie
eingeschweißt becher ich schenkte ein
und wir stießen an auf deinen erfolg
sagte ich möglichst lange währen
schade das du nicht klavierspiels sagte
franziska sonst könntest du mich
begleiten und wir könnten zusammen auf
tournee gehen sie trank ihren becher in
einem zug aus und sagte sie gehe ins bad
kurz darauf hörte ich das rauschen der
dusche es schien eine ewigkeit zu dauern
bis franziska aus dem bad kam sie trug
no sleep & t shirt ich sah es immer noch
auf dem sofa und sie streckte sich neben
mich und legte den kopf auf meinen schoß
ich bin hundemüde sagte sie und lächelte
ihr gesicht sah so von oben und im
rechten winkel betrachtet ganz anders
aus als sonst sie wirkte jünger und
irgendwie offener ich weiß nicht wofür
ich stehe hier eine haarsträhne aus dem
gesicht streichen dh mit einem finger
fuhrig ihren ohrmuscheln entlang sie
trug keinen bh ihre brustwarzen zeichnen
sich ab unter dem dünnen stoff des t
shirts
und schaust du denn hin sagte sie und
lächelte
in meiner erinnerung streichelte ich
ganz sanft ihre brüste ihren bauch aber
ist das überhaupt möglich oder bilde ich
mir das nur ein weil ich es mir so sehr
wünschte
wir schwiegen irgendwann richtete
franziska sich auf und sagte ihr seid
als ig ins bett kommst du auch
ich ging ins bad wo ich mich und putze
die zähne dann stand ich lange nur da
betrachtete mich im spiegel ich weiß
nicht worauf ich wartete ich hielt den
atem an und lauschte ob aus dem
nebenraum noch etwas zu hören war als
ich endlich zurück ins zimmer trat war
franziska eingeschlafen ich legte mich
zu ihr ohne aufzuwachen rückte sie näher
und drückte sich an mich
ich habe später oft an jene nacht in der
waldschänke gedacht habe mir ausgemalt
was alles hätte geschehen können wenn
ich früher aus dem bad gekommen wäre
vielleicht hat die franziska ja darauf
gewartet dass ich den ersten schritt
machen sie hatte gesagt sie liebe mich
nicht aber das lag jahre zurück als wir
noch kinder waren gefühle konnten sich
ändern
nachdem ich sie am nächsten tag nach
hause gefahren hatte entwarf ich einen
brief an sie aber als ich ihn noch
einmal las kam er mir so wird und
unentschieden vor dass ich ihn wegwarf
oder habe ich ihn ausgewählt weil es
nicht mehr ich weiß nur noch dass ich
nie mehr so verliebt war in meinem leben
wie damals zugleich glücklich und
verzweifelt
manchmal wenn ich mich mit franziska
traf konnte ich kaum atmen das eine oder
andere mal weinte ich sogar nachdem wir
uns gesehen hatten jetzt kommt es mir
verrückt vor um eine frau zu weinen aber
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das reife
bedeutete oder nur gleichgültigkeit
das letzte mal geweint habe ich nach dem
tod meiner mutter
was würde ich franziska heute schreiben
ich habe dich immer geliebt ich habe
mein ganzes leben lang auf dich gewartet
nein nicht gewagt ich war immer da ich
war immer für dich da auch wenn wir uns
nie mehr gesehen haben
vielleicht ist es gut dass wir nicht
zusammengekommen sind eine beziehung
hatte meiner liebe nie genügt hätte sie
nur beschädigen können abnutzen wie
einen gegenstand oder ein wort in
gebrauch
warum ich gerade dich geliebt habe ich
weiß es nicht ich kann es dir ebenso
wenig erklären wie damals vor fast 40
jahren als wir uns küssten als du mir
sagtest du liebst mich nicht ich bin in
all den jahren kein bisschen schlauer
geworden nur älter
klammer bisher so gut
vielen dank für diesen abend schön dass
sie da waren es gibt ein zitat von
eichendorff das habe ich gestern gelesen
das finde ich passt irgendwie ganz gut
vielleicht zu ihren figuren da heißt es
wir sehen uns nach hause und wissen
nicht wohin
[Musik]
kommen sie gut nach hause
[Applaus]
[Musik]